as a circle there isn't a problem that
we cannot solve we have cameras in place
all over the world right now terrorists
can no longer hide where is all that
data go everything is stored and
analyzed here because you did ever they
see fit
I want the truth did you think this was
just a camera I'm the only one who can
do this
things we hide and get us in trouble we
can't be here so may is there anything
you want to tell us you sir come April
28th I am a believer in the
perfectibility of human being as a
circle we can finally realize our
potential when we are our best selves
there isn't a problem that we cannot
solve we can cure any disease and we can
and hunger imagine the human rights
implication the possibilities are
endless your payment it was for 78 13 in
the bill with 478 31 thank you you
called the job at the circle have a
drink have a good time and stay excited
direct the circle and I'm a how are you
Garin here we'll be doing a training I
first started it took me weeks to get
the hang of it believe me
you're doing fine she come visit me at
work full time you might think I was
there to clean the toilet
everyone really likes you their works
been exemplary strongly but you're
asking to several events sorry my dad
had an episode and I was home helping
out it was not related to an MS I've
been looking into your parents situation
and I have an idea so I was thinking it
would make sense for a native spoke to
come on the circle health plan I want to
see how much they value what you've
learned for my family man you are a
valued part of the circle we care about
everybody you care about may have only
been with us for a few months but she
has made quite an impression so may do
you think you became better or worse
when you are being watched
we have cameras in place all over the
world right now we used to go on
adventures we used to have fun and see
things and now it's all filtered through
this if this really seem okay to you
[Music]
I didn't create this not what I had in
mind things at the circle they need to
change
[Music]
everything recorded being broadcast it
storage analog here
however they see fit no matter what it's
called
[Music]
knowing is good
of knowing everything is that
so me is there anything you want to tell
us
[Music]
you